the Joe Rogan experience I had a friend
was like that over the time that I knew
him when I've met him when he was in his
20s and as time went on into his 30s he
became more and more bitter and angry he
wasn't very attractive and he would have
these interactions with women and they
would wind up no dumping him or abusing
him and and he he just got [ __ ] angry
and then as he got older he was just an
angry guy like he just hated women it
would be just because of rejection yeah
he associated them with pain and
emotional discomfort and so for a guy
like that and he he wasn't into the game
or anything like that but for some of
those guys that are vulnerable like you
know like this this insel thing right a
lot of these men involuntary celibates
they did it develop these form groups
and yeah subreddits and when they meet
up and you know talk about what to do
and maybe I'll get facial surgery and
yeah look no further they want women
yeah ultimately that's a compromise they
want a real woman
mm-hm you know they just they just got a
[ __ ] roll the dice
genetically yeah I don't know what ton
about I mean I've read articles about
and said but what is can they not get
hookers or don't want to or well that's
a problem because hookers are illegal
right like you know if you get hookers
you got to go through some sort of shady
black Marta [ __ ] dantana I think Dan
Tana's yeah yeah we will have you
convinced you'll go there with a [ __ ]
newspaper there's no there's no hookers
you'll be pretending you sit here and
wait no just read the paper and they'll
show up yeah there's no hookers yeah I
remember I used to go to the four
seasons all the time and people would
come in like ma'am are you here to sit
like they always thought I was a
prostitute why they're in the lobby yeah
four seasons in Beverly Hills Peninsula
yeah oh they be like ma'am are you here
to see somebody or you like if I ever
showed up alone because hookers just
like wander around the Four Seasons
lobby oh how weird editorial little
coyotes oh my god of course I should
call my Odie's when we used to go to the
sky bar across the street from is that
still just like the Mondrian sky bar
I think so it's across Montgomery story
yeah I used to have a whole bit about
them the Coyotes because they were like
they would prey on these guys I was I
was hanging out once with me and a
friend of mine and we heard this
conversation between this fat balding
guy and this really pretty girl with big
tits and and he was like do coke do you
do coke she's like yeah sometimes
and I was like cuz it's like damn they
would prey on these vulnerable you know
like like a pug now like a pug that got
out of the yard
that's it felt like they because these
women would have this feral look in
their eyes like when when you're down to
[ __ ] people for money and that's how
you're getting by and you got some
cocaine in your purse and maybe a few
dollars and you probably don't eat well
no and you don't have a lot of money and
then whatever money you do have he's
spending on drugs or whatever and
there's a feeling that you get when
you're around them on here they're feral
yeah every day were hustling yeah
they're hustling yeah and they're
looking for these vulnerable guys with
money yeah and so that's what you know
that place would be the place where they
would go
[Applause]